this year for the first time ever
skateboarding is being featured at the
olympics
now skateboarding is a relatively new
sport which means there's still time for
me to leave my mark on it
and that's exactly what we're going to
do today with the help of my friend
tony hawk
this is amber invents a new trick
[Music]
hey everybody i'm here with
skateboarding legend
tony hawk hi tony hi how are you he's my
friend now
and we are going to learn the basics of
skateboarding and then
tony and i together are going to create
skateboarding's newest trick
the amber are you ready
for which part all of it dude okay yes
i'm ready
tony what's the first thing you need to
know when riding a skateboard
wheels go down wheels go down and they
will be in motion
so you have to anticipate that motion
all right which means that when you're
standing you need to be leaning
towards the direction it's moving okay
okay front foot
is just behind these bolts right
a little bit of an angle that looks
pretty good right feels awful great good
and then you want to push with this foot
over here on this side of the board oh
that feels better and then when you push
off
then you set your other foot in place
that's it we're gonna get this i do not
feel scared
okay here we go i'm ready push off
that's it you are skating okay lean
forward on this foot more
there you go yay ready watch
oh this ain't nothing oh i have this
so you're gonna compete for team usa now
yeah finally
you got it okay i'm letting you go
oh oh my god that's it you just learned
how to skateboard
first try okay that was impressive
i feel impressed with myself
first thing you push off what is another
thing you need to know
about skateboarding another basic well
turning
oh my god great turning is basically
just
leaning from your toes to your heels and
and
that's a card
you can generate speed that way too so
lean towards the toes
both toes there you go
now towards the heels now back towards
the toes
that's good hey falling is a big part of
skateboarding
this is a lot more sideways than i
thought i gotta be honest
i thought i would be standing like this
on the skateboard that's
called skiing
the foundation trick to start every
trick is the ollie
the motion of an ollie is that you snap
your back
foot down on the tail yep so that lifts
the nose up
yep and then your front foot in that
same moment
slides forward and that brings it up and
it looks like magic yeah there you go
all you gotta do is jump straight up
ready one
i think we should race first one to
the grease spot wins don't go easy on me
go very easy on me okay okay are you
ready
ready let's go
hey you're doing it
straight enough yeah there you go
no no no no no no that's it oh no oh you
won
by all measures you're an experienced
skater now right yeah i know what i'm
doing
so you want to look like you know what
you're doing if you're not skating yeah
and that is how you pick up your board
something i can do oh
that was it that's it you're a skater
my work is done tony come back
we still have to create the amber oh
okay
i'm gonna teach it to you all right
please do okay so first
you take your skateboard okay and then
you put your little bottom on it
and then you squish with your fingies
okay it's the amber that's the ember
it's safe
it's effective it doesn't hurt
i don't want to break it to you but i
think that's been done
[Laughter]
oh not like that that's the amber right
there you have a signature fall
how's that yeah that worked
how much do you think the amber should
be worth in competition
well personally i think it should be a
high scoring trick
i give it like 80 80 90. yes you hear
that yeah
tony hawk is being nice to me
um tony what advice would you give
athletes who are brave enough
to do the amber in competition um be
careful of your speed
because high speed ambers that's an
amber alert
[Music]
see what i did there i like it you being
nerd
tony do you have any advice for all the
athletes on team usa
uh yeah my advice is to approach it with
confidence
um get your line dialed and have a
strategy
if you fall tony thank you so much for
all of your help today sure
later dudes threw us in amber
one for the road yes
there is a danger factor there it's
danger yeah
[Music]
danger
my mom's gonna be so mad i did that
you